if everything is destined by Allah and
if I commit any sin then who is to blame
if I am destined to commit a murder and
then I commit a murder but naturally I
will not be responsible for it it is
Allah who has destined it therefore he
will be responsible then why should I be
punished for
this as far as the question of the SC is
concerned it's a common question asked
by Muslims as as non-muslim about the of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala and it's
difficult to
understand I'd like to give an example
for people to know that Allah subhana wa
ta'ala
has has knowledge of the Unseen he has
knowledge of the future let me give you
an example that if in a classroom there
is a teacher who teaches the students
after one year has passed
before the examination the teacher
predicts that this child he will come
first class first this child he'll get a
second class this child C he will fail
and once the examination takes place and
when the results are out student a gets
the first class first student B he gets
a second class student C he fails now
the question I would like to ask is that
just because the teacher predicted that
the student C would fail can the student
C blame the teacher saying that because
the teacher predicted that I will fail I
have
failed but natur the answer is no the
teacher predicted the student a will get
a first class first because he knew that
the student was studious and he was
intelligent student B he was Aver
student student see he used to pay
hookie he used to Bunk school he never
used to study never used to do the
homework so based on that the teacher
predicted that student C would fail but
student C cannot blame the teacher
because the teacher predicted I will
fail therefore I failed the student
himself is responsible similarly Allah
subhana wa ta'ala
hasab for example when a human being
comes at a crossroad there are five
roads from which he can choose Road one
2 3 4 5 he has the free will he can
choose any he chooses Road three
and that's already mentioned in the
destiny that he will choose Road Three
it is not because Allah has mentioned he
will choose Road Three that he has
chosen Road Three it is because he will
be choosing Road Three Allah subhana
waala writes in advance because he has
like how the teacher predicts in advance
so Allah knows this person has a choice
he can choose any of the roads from the
five roads available but he chooses the
road three so Allah knows in advance he
will be choosing Road Three therefore he
mentions in the in the that he'll be
choosing Road Three now once he goes to
Road Three after some time he comes on
another Crossroad 1 2 3 he chooses Road
Three now because he will be choosing
Road Three Allah knows in advance heab
so he's mentioned that after some time
he'll come at another Crossroad and this
particular person will choose again rad
three it is not because Allah has
mentioned in t that he will choose Road
three that is choosing Road Three it is
because he has chosen Road Three Allah
has written in advance it's a bit
confusing but you realize that Allah is
same way a
person if he wants to earn his
livelihood he has both choices either he
can strive hard work hard and do honest
job and earn that money or he can rob or
he can steal the choices is this person
prefers to steal Allah knows in advance
that at the age of 25 he has option of
working hard and earning honest living
or
stealing but this person steals so Allah
knows in advance he will be stealing
therefore Allah has the he will steal it
is not because Allah has written that he
has stolen it is because he will be
stealing Allah in advance so similarly
if a person commits murder it's his
choice he can either not commit murder
or he can commit murder choice is and he
commits murder who's to blame he's to
blame so here we realize that Allah is
so that's the reason there's a saying in
Udu there's a very good
couplet which
says which means that make yourself so
great that before Allah writes the
destiny he will ask you that what is
your wish